There are people in my audience and elsewhere
who are getting too confident about the upcoming
presidential election.
I'm scared by it.
You guys are scaring me.
And so what I want to do today is to make
the case that not only could Donald Trump
win reelection, nothing major really needs
to change for him to win reelection.
He could be winning right now from an Electoral
College standpoint.
So if you don't look at the details and you
say, oh, Biden's plus 10, Biden's plus twelve,
there was a poll where Biden was plus fifteen.
Seems like Biden's winning easily and he's
also winning key battleground states.
Biden is going to run away with a historic
Electoral College victory.
No, no.
If by the end of this clip, I have not convinced
you that we should be very careful of interpreting
the data we have in that way.
Then I will have failed to do my job.
I deserve to be canceled.
Hello.
If by the end of this segment, I've not convinced
you that we need to be very, very careful
about what's going on.
So let's start with national polling.
Whenever there there's a poll that says Joe
Biden is up 12.
Joe Biden is up 10.
Joe Biden is up 15.
It gets a ton of attention.
And certainly if Joe Biden wins the popular
vote by 10 to 12 or 15, Trump's done.
That's not actually what the mathematical
case today is.
Let's look at the numbers today and understand
the numbers.
First of all, the polls that had Biden up
ten, twelve and fifteen, we're not getting
any more of those polls.
OK.
The last poll where Biden was up double digits
was July 20, 30 was up 10.
More recently.
Biden is only up three in a number of polls.
And on average, Biden is up by six point four.
Six point four is very different than 15.
My friends.
So six point four still sounds pretty good.
But understand that if you look at any individual
poll, you have to understand the margin of
error.
Hugely important.
So, for example, the latest YouGov poll has
a three point three percent margin of error.
So when the YouGov poll says that Biden is
winning by nine 49 to 40, Trump's 40 could
actually be forty three point three.
And it would still be within the margin of
error of the poll.
Biden's forty nine could really be forty five
point seven.
So a poll which promotes as a headline Biden
plus nine could really be Biden plus.
Two point four.
And the poll would still be correct.
This is what we.
This is why we have a confidence interval
and a margin of error.
If Biden is really only winning by two point
four, Trump could win the Electoral College.
Remember, we have polling for the national
popular vote, but we have an electoral college
system in 2016.
Hillary won the popular vote by I think it
was two point one or two point two, but lost
the Electoral College.
So for people who are saying what could happen
to allow Trump to catch up to Biden, nothing
has to happen within the margin of error to
day.
Donald Trump has the support where he could
win the Electoral College.
If we have similar battleground results to
those in 2016, you don't need an October surprise
when the current lead for Trump might only
be.
I'm sorry, the current lead for Biden might
only be two point four.
Trump won 2016 with a two point one percent
deficit in the popular vote.
So that's national popular vote polling.
Let's now go to step two.
You might say Biden is winning hugely in key
battleground states.
Well, remember, in 2016, the national popular
vote polls were accurate, but there were state
polls that didn't get it right.
State polls had some problems in 2016.
So Hillary was winning the polling in Wisconsin.
Going into the election, Trump won Wisconsin.
That's just one example.
So once you concede the national polling,
that looks like a big lead for Biden could
actually be like a two point lead for Biden.
State polling was off in some states in 2016.
You have to come to the conclusion that Biden
might not really be winning electorally right
now.
And then lastly, I talked about this yesterday.
When you look at voter registration, it doesn't
look that great.
It is true that in many states, if you look
only at new registrations, meaning people
who have never been registered before, who
maybe were not even 18 years old in 2016,
when you look just at new registrations, Democrats
have an advantage over Republicans.
They've registered more new voters.
But as I told you yesterday in Florida, Pennsylvania,
Arizona, Iowa and North Carolina, in terms
of the number of registered Democrats versus
Republicans today versus 2016, the advantage
has been in favor of Republicans and against
Democrats.
And the reasons for this are people who have
moved from one state to another.
People who have switched party registrations,
deaths.
This is separate from who is going to choose
to vote.
But this is not the type of data you want
to see.
If you want to be confident that Joe Biden
is going to run away with this thing.
So when you step back and you say, well, the
polls, if you account for margin of error,
look very similar to 2016.
There were state polls in 2016 that were wrong.
And then you realize, you know, over the next
three months, if the economy improves a little
bit.
If Corona virus, it gets better if we get
a vaccine or a good treatment, that Trump
will try to take credit for a one or one and
a half point swing from where we are today
in Trump's direction.
And Trump wins the Electoral College.
So I hope that I have convinced you that we
need to be far more skeptical about these
Bidens running away with it, ideas that we
are starting to see.
You must run as if we are behind.
This is going to be a huge fight.
It actually doesn't look nearly as good as
some are claiming.
And I'm very worried some of you are worrying
me that we are getting complacent, that some
people think the data clearly points to Biden
running away with this review, this video.
If you need to fact check me, go item by item.
And if you do, you can come to only one conclusion,
which is that there is not actually evidence
to say right now that Joe Biden is going to
easily win in November.
He might win hugely and he might lose.
And we've got to we're going to have to fight
this.
We're going to have more coverage of this
on the show's Instagram page.
David Pakman shows our Instagram handle while
you are there.
You can also follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman.
You should see what's going on in my backyard,
which you can find out on my Instagram David
Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot.com.